good afternoon cs109 how are you guys
doing today
fantastic that's what I like to hear oh
we have another Wonderful class we get
to learn about another incredible
beautiful natural phenomena that's going
to allow you to solve some interesting
cool problems in the real world uh so
we're both going to just see something
beautiful and we're going to learn
something useful which makes her a
Wonderful class uh stay tuned and we
will learn about poisson but not the
fish kind the probability kind
uh at the end of today's lecture we are
going to pull some data from
um the the herdat database which is the
US database of uh all known hurricanes
in the Atlantic and we'll try and answer
questions about what's the probability
of sort of extreme weather events that
we may be seeing more of
but before we get into that it is
important that you know what we're
building upon
we are in this wonderful part of cs109
where we are learning about random
variables and random variables are like
a gift to you by previous mathematicians
in random variable World a mathematician
will come up with a narrative
do a lot of math for that narrative
package it all together into this
wonderful package of a random variable
and then if you recognize that narrative
in a real world problem you can uh
inherit all the mathematics that is
given to you a random variable though at
the end of the day is a very simple
thing it's just a variable which takes
on values probabilistically has semantic
meaning we've been talking about
discrete random variables and the most
important thing for a discrete random
variable is the relationship between the
values it can take on and the
probability of those values and we have
talked about a couple summary statistics
like expectation and then last class we
talked about variance and standard
deviation
one of the most useful ones we've seen
so far started with this Narrative of
let's say we had n coin flips and every
coin flip had a probability P of coming
up heads could we package all the
mathematics for talking about the
probability of exactly K heads out of
those end coin flips and we did that
packaging of the math and then we
realized that like oh my gosh this is so
useful we could use it for any story
where you have independent trials and
you want to count the number of
successes in those independent trials
where they each have the same
probability P of success
we introduced our first classic random
variable the binomial distribution and
as soon as you see a story that fits
that coin flip one you just say you know
my random variable is not any random
variable it's a super special one called
a binomial random variable and you have
to give the parameters n and p how many
trials are there in your narrative and
what's the probability of success in
each triable trial and then you
automatically inherit all of this for
free you inherit the probability Mass
function you don't have to derive this
from scratch which is good because let's
save you some time that probably Mass
function can be expressed either as an
equation or it can be expressed as a
graph any way that you can really give
the relationship between values and
probabilities I take on fair game you
could give somebody a function if you're
a Sci-Fi stats we are going to start
building up these cards of these classic
random variables this is from the course
reader so we now have the card for the
binomial we have the card for the also a
simpler one of Bernoulli it's like a
binomial where you just have one coin
flip
Good Times
if you know something as a binomial you
don't just get the probably Mass
function you also get equations for
expectation and variance and that will
be true for all the random variables
that we direct we discover
okay
now this isn't reviewed that we've
covered but it's just something that you
we're going to use in today's class
um which is this definition of the
natural exponent uh and I'm just going
to put this on the board and we're going
to see if you can find a place in class
when you can use it and you're wondering
like wow that's a very beautiful limit I
wonder who came up with it the same
person who discovered the binomial wow
what a time to be alive eat a lot of
math
just like us okay and that's what we
have for review before we get into
today's great topic
okay
I have a story for you
I would like us to think about a
scenario and the probability that
underlies it and the scenario I'd like
to think about is algorithmic ride
sharing you know if you've ever gotten a
shared lift ride for example there's a
lot of probability that goes on under
the hood to make a decision under
uncertainty as who should go into which
cards
and it turns out there's this beautiful
natural phenomena which is occurring
underneath the hood that makes this math
pretty reasonable to do
so I want us to think about a scenario
so I once lived here oh that was such a
good time anyways
let's say I clicked I want to have a
shared ride the shared ride Service uh
now has a probability question they have
to decide you know what's the
probability of getting K requests within
this area in the next one minute
and you know depending on that they
might figure out how much they should
charge me for my ride or they might make
other decisions based off it but there's
really this core understanding of
how many people are going to ask for a
ride in the same one minute
you could tell me the average the
expectation but that's not that useful
for making decisions instead I want to
know what's the probability of one
request what's the probability of two
requests what's the probability of three
requests was it probably a four request
I'd like to know the whole probability
Mass function over the number of
requests in one minute
well you know let's just constrain this
problem a bit let's just say we're just
talking about within a small area of
where I made my request
and
the interesting thing about these
requests is that they'll be coming in
over time so over one minute you know
maybe one request comes 10 seconds later
maybe one request comes 40 seconds later
and these requests will be coming over
this new dimension for us to think about
and what an interesting and deeply
fascinating Dimension it will become
so we don't have mathematics for this
yet
but we can develop it based on what we
do know so far now one final piece of
information the only piece of
information I have yet to give you is
that your ride sharing app knows one
piece of data they know on average how
many requests come within one minute to
this area it's not a lot of information
to work on but it turns out if you
understand this beautiful underlying
phenomena in our natural world you can
use a tiny amount of information and
drive a whole bunch of meaning does that
sound exciting or what shall we do this
okay yeah
now you don't have the tools for it yet
but we learned about the binomial
distribution in Wednesday's class
and what we're going to do is we're
going to hack that binomial distribution
to come up with a hacky answer to the
probability of number of requests within
one minute
here's my crazy hacky idea bear with me
for a moment
I'm going to take my minute which is
continuous in all the beautiful
complexity that time is continuous and
I'm going to chop it into seconds and
make it discreet I'm going to say my
minute is actually 60 discrete seconds
and I'm going to do something even
happier
I'm going to say every second I either
get zero quests or one request you're
like what if you get two requests I'm
like no either zero requests or one
request every single second
and
that's really hacky
but once I've done this I've done this
really crazy thing I've taken time and
I've recast it as a story of flipping
coins
because now if I want to know how many
requests I get in 60 seconds well I'm
gonna flip a coin for every second if
it's heads I get a request if it's Tails
I don't get a request
cool narrative right totally
mind-bending what a weird thing to do
but there is a problem
this coin flipping story that we now
have a little bit of practice with
requires two numbers how many times do
you flip your coin
60 I know that one feeling good and then
you're like but what is the probability
of success on every coin flip and you're
like
I don't know I'm like going on the edge
of my seat I'm making this stuff up what
is the probability of heads okay I'm
trying this really hacky thing here can
you guys help me out can you tell me
what would be a reasonable choice for
the probability of success
if I did this hacky thing of took a
minute broke it down to 60 seconds and
thought about the number of requests as
being coin flips the number of heads in
60 coin flips remember the one piece of
information I've given you is that on
average there's five requests per minute
talk about with the person next to you
let's see if we can crack this puzzle uh
help me out on my hacky solution
okay okay let's talk about to get I
can't wait to talk about I know I just
like you guys were just like having a
nice calm day and you're like yeah
binomial good times and I throw you the
deep end we're like talking about time
all of a sudden we're taking minutes and
chopping them into seconds
craziness before I even get into any
answers somebody's got a question
somebody's like what did you do like
what's this coin Flip's doing in my my
Uber pool
Yeah question
doesn't this assume that it takes one
second to process a request like would
your probability be different
broke up the minute into a milliseconds
or 10 seconds then you asked such a good
question if I could just paraphrase a
little bit you're like you chose 60
seconds wouldn't this be pretty
different if you chose different amounts
of time uh yeah those are pretty
arbitrary decision for me to have made
we're gonna explore the arbitrariness of
that decision we'll try a couple
different ways of breaking it up but for
now I just thought 60 was pretty
reasonable
well let's talk about this in a moment
though because we could have a good
conversation you'd be like Chris it's
not really reasonable uh and then but
but first let's see where this gets us
and then let's talk about what it's not
really good for that is a very good
question though why 60 I just chose it
okay
so
I wanted to model this as coin flips
crazy way to think about this problem
but it requires me to say what's the
probability of heads on every coin flip
recall that in a binomial the coin flips
always have the same probability of
heads it's not always 0.5 it can be a
different P it's just every coin flip
has the same P probability of being
heads that is one of the rules of the
binomial
so
there is no perfect answer here but like
what's your best guess for what P should
be to make my world consistent
one over twelve how did you get there
five over 60. so I we need the expected
value of coin flips via both parentheses
to agree so you said five which
conveniently is Lambda over 12 which is
the same as
sorry over 60. thank you
which is the same I was using Lambda as
my symbol for the average request per
second and N is my number of coin flips
okay
so your claim is let's say we set P to
be 5 over 60. now we're going to
simulate requests by having some some
poor person go and flip coins and
they're going to flip 60 coins and it's
a special coin that comes up heads only
with a 5 or 60 probability
so your claim is that if you flip 60
coins and they each have a 5 over 60
chance
the binomial expectation says the
expected expected value of a binomial is
p so this number times n which is 60
which would be 5. hey that's nice and
consistent if you choose this number
your expected number of successes in 60
coin flips is going to be five
great
so
this is wonderful we now have everything
we can need to do to totally hack this
problem we can solve this problem using
a binomial distribution
we're going to say every second you
either get your request or you don't so
we can define a random variable which is
the number of requests in a minute
and I'm going to call it x what a boring
name man I miss programming where you
can get the like descriptive names and
in probability this is like X and Y but
like whatever we'll live with it X is
the number of requests in one minute and
this crazy thing I've said is that now X
is modeled as coin flips
60 coin flips the probability of heads
on any one coin flip is 5 over 60 and
we're going to count the number of heads
once we've done this we inherit this
formula and it's such a funny way of
writing the relationship between
assignments to X and a probability but
that's what this is saying it's saying
if you put in a zero for K it'll be
telling you the probability that you get
zero requests
if you put one in for K it's telling you
the probability that you get one coin
flip which is our analogy for getting
one request in a minute if you put in
you know
60 for K it'll tell you the probability
that you got six to your requests in
your minute good business
let's put in a concrete number let's put
in a three if you put in a three we
could substitute 16 for n number of coin
flips three and four K that's our query
and we can put 5 over 60 in for p that's
the P that we chose to make this whole
expectation work out and if you did this
then you would be able to get an exact
number for the probability of getting
three requests within your minute
great we've solved it we're done give us
the next algorithmic challenge we're
ready
um
but there is this wonderful question
there's a lot of problems with this it
feels arbitrary why did I choose 60. and
I think there was this deep Insight in
the question I was asked earlier is if
you're flipping a coin
it doesn't allow you for you to get two
requests in the same second
does it seem possible to get two
yeah Bernal Heights is a popular place
you can definitely get two requests in
the same second so
if this isn't that good
is there a simple thing we could do to
make it better
everybody just yell out what would you
do
more divisions yeah we have the power of
computers at our fingertips why stop at
60 when we could do sixty thousand
I'm gonna do the exact same thought
experiment but instead of doing 60 coin
flips for my it's still one minute
I'm gonna do 60 000 coin flips and every
coin flip is representing whether I get
a request within one millisecond
uh now n is 60 what happens to P is it
still 5 over 60
if it was 5 or 60 then you would be
getting way more than five requests a
minute and that's the one piece of
historical data that we're working with
uh what is the new P if we do ten
thousand or sorry sixty thousand rather
five over sixty thousand is that a
bigger number or a smaller number okay
small number yes
uh so
same problem we just have more more time
frames and a lower probability of
getting a success in time frames but
we're still solving what's the
probability of different numbers of
requests within a minute there is a
question
question when
when we break it up into such small
parts I'm wondering if the binomial
equation allows us in any way to change
the probability over time like make a
more frequent for life that it's such a
good question it is the binomial is a
beautiful thing it's near and dear to my
heart it does so much for me but it
doesn't change probabilities
probabilities are constant so in the
binomial it's always assuming that P is
not changing if you make p change you
would have to derive a new probability
Mass function and it will be a more
complicated one depending on how you're
allowing your P to change it would be so
nice if binomial did that and it does
somebody we should appreciate it but it
doesn't do that
good good question
okay so we need a constant P we're going
to use this constant P okay
once again the number of requests within
my minute I'm going to use x and it's
now still this process of flipping coin
flips so it's like I got a Tails I got
Tails I get the hills I got Tails I got
heads that means I got a request at five
milliseconds into my minute
and you can continue this process and
the number of heads is going to be our
model for the number of requests and now
we can say that X's model is a binomial
and again it's a binomial but now n is
60 000 and P is going to be 5 divided by
sixty thousand
and again we can still ask the question
what's the probability that X takes on a
value say three and if you put three
into this you'll actually get a very
similar number but this will just be a
little bit more accurate because the
assumptions are better
it's less likely that you get two
requests within the same millisecond and
for that reason this seems like just a
straight Improvement
but could we do better
like what what's smaller than a
millisecond
an infinitely small sliver of time we're
gonna go there are you guys ready to do
this let's let's take a moment and get
ready for a wonderful Adventure we are
going to take the binomial to the Limit
we're going to see what happens when we
get smaller and smaller and smaller
until we get infinitely small buckets uh
we had a beautiful place of math for us
to be
are you guys ready
I can't even draw them they're so small
but we can still start to write out our
binomial distribution so we could say I
still care about the number requests
it's still one minute even though we've
gone into the infinity that is the
amount of units of time within one
minute
X is going to be binomial but now
there's infinite coin flips and every
coin flip has a five over infinity
probability of being hands
whoa I know the we I'll tell you about
the first person who did this he must
have been feeling crazy he's like you
know what
I'm doing it I'm just gonna go to the
edge today
and so he did
he thought what if you took this
equation and you thought about it in the
limit as n goes to Infinity notice I
don't have a p I've already substituted
in 5 over n and we're thinking about
this not as 5 goes Infinity 5 will
always be constant that's the thing
that's one thing that stayed true in
this crazy thought experiment is as n
goes to Infinity the number of slices
okay
let's do this let's see something
beautiful you guys want to see something
beautiful let's jump into what happens
when you take this binomial and take it
into the limit
oh
where do you even start when you want to
write out something like this
what I do is I start by expanding at the
beginning it's one of the many moves you
can do and expanding in this case can
look like take this term and expand it
we've already looked earlier in class
about what is the definition of this
combinatorics sometimes we use that
notation but it's short for this
equation n choose K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial times K
factorial great
and then see this term
um
1 minus Lambda Over N to the power of n
minus K as you know when you subtract
exponents it's equivalent to if you had
this raised to one exponent divided by
this raised to another exponent so I've
simplified this term
earlier in class I wrote this beautiful
equation on the board and it's going to
be our first hint that something truly
gorgeous is going to happen
because one of these terms here as n
goes to Infinity
approaches this beautiful natural
exponent to the power of negative Lambda
does anyone see that term is it this one
is it this one
is it this one yeah yeah
that whole term when n goes to Infinity
that whole term is going to be a very
nice e to the power of negative Lambda
now my notation's got a little
now limit as n goes to Infinity well
there's not an N there so we're in a
good place
I also did
I took this term on the base and I said
it's one
we're going into limits you know that's
a wild place to be but my claim is as n
goes to Infinity that whole denominator
starts to look like a constant let's
break it down as n goes to Infinity this
starts to look like zero because five
divided by Infinity is pretty small and
then you have 1 minus zero and that
starts to look like a one and one to
raise to any power just looks like a one
so this whole honking or expression has
become something beautiful okay yay are
we done is that where the beauty ends no
we're just getting started
okay I'm just gonna do a little bit of
rearranging
you know when you're looking at an
equation like this you might think I
want to get all like terms together in
this case let's take everything that's
got an n in it and let's move it to this
side
and we're going to reserve this for
terms that don't have n in it and that's
a convenient choice because we're
thinking about the limit in terms of n
so as n goes to Infinity this is not
really going to be changing
we have one last task to think about
what does this mean
as n goes to Infinity
you have n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial and then
you also have this n to the power of K
n factorial divided by n minus K
factorial is maybe something worth
thinking about and it's something that
you'll see a lot in different
derivations in probability let's put
real numbers there if I gave you 7
factorial
divided by
7 minus 3 factorial
if you wrote this out this would be like
seven six five four three two one and on
the bottom you'd have
7 minus three is four so you have 4 3 2
1. and a bunch of these terms cancel out
you know this cancels this cancels this
cancels this cancels this cancels and
you're just left with like this is
basically saying for loop from seven
decrementing by one each time until you
get to this number and you're going to
be multiplying those together
so in our case what we've got going on
is we have n factorial divided by n
minus K factorial and that will look
like n
times n minus 1
times n minus 2 and remember K is kind
of a small number it's like the three
requests within the minute that we're
going to be querying so let's say that
you know just K is 3.
so n times n minus 1 times n minus 2
times M minus 3 great
um and that's covering this whole term n
factorial divided by n minus K factorial
we're still left with an N to the power
of K
I feel like I have an off by 1 here
if you're subtracting off
I went I left one more here than I
should have if K was 3 you got to stop
it too
okay the only term left here that I
haven't thought about is this n to the
power of K and let's expand it n and n
and this is in the case where k equals
three or
I'm just doing it for demonstration
purposes so that we can reason about
what happens as as n goes to Infinity
if N is a n is like three these are
pretty different numbers
if n is 10
though this is like 10 10 10 and this is
10 9 8 and they start to look like a
little bit some more similar numbers
what if N is a hundred they start to
look even more similar as n becomes
Infinity
this really starts to look like n times
n times n divided by n times n times n
now this is not a rigorous class on
limits rather this is a class on
probability so I want you to see this
beauty and I want to give you guys the
intuition for why this whole term here
as n goes to Infinity this term goes to
one
and you're like wow and you're left with
you know it's because this looks like
one and you're left with this and you're
like what's my next limit and you're
like there's no more n's left in my
equation I'm done and then you look at
your equation and Tears start welling up
in your eyes you're like it's so
beautiful I've got that 5 to the power
of my query the natural base to the
power of the negative uh rate that was
the five divide my query factorial
and that's it
we have taken the binomial in the limit
and what seemed like a scary Endeavor
led to such a beautiful simple equation
and this beautiful simple equation
carries so much power in it it means if
something's following this process where
we think you know events are coming
independently over time
all you need is to know Lambda and if
somebody gives you Lambda you can infer
all this structure over the probability
of getting one request two requests
three requests four requests and this is
the powerful technology that people in
ride sharing can use to make interesting
decisions under uncertainty
so
maybe I'll pause here for a second
because that was a wild ride yeah
up here okay yes it is from this
definition of the natural exponent so
this is something that oh you look into
the there's a cool Wikipedia page if you
want to go deeper into why this is true
but this is just one of the dilemmas
that I came into class with
yes
because the differences between the
numbers are arbitrarily small yes like K
being a small number and N being
something close to Infinity means that
this really looks like n times n times n
as n goes to Infinity like this minus
two means nothing when it comes to
Infinity
okay good good question
okay what a beautiful math proof
the person who first did this math proof
did it in uh the 17 in the 1800s and is
but Simone denisong uh who was a French
mathematician he published his first
paper at 18. he became a professor when
he was 21. he published over 300 papers
in his lifetime
this is hilarious quote he reportedly
said life is good for only two things
discovering mathematics and teaching
mathematics and teaching mathematics is
a fun thing Discovery mathematics is a
fun thing but I don't know Sima I think
there's a little bit more to life but I
guess to each their own
um and for a celebrity look alike I'm
going with French Martin Freeman
because he's a
visit for mathematics he was the crazy
individual who took the binomial to the
limit for the first time the poisson
random variable is named after him in
the poisson random variable needs so
little information as input it's amazing
all you need to give to define a poisson
random variable is you just need to give
that five the average number of events
within one time period and you could
immediately know the probability of
number of events within the time period
so we often call that parameter that
five the rate and we'll use Lambda for
the rate
what are the values that this random
variable can take on
when there is 60 seconds when we took
our minute and broke into 60 seconds it
could take on any value from 0 to 60.
when we went up to 60 000 though we were
thinking about this metaphor with 60 000
coin flips and technically a random
variable could take on any value from
the range zero to sixty thousand but
when we took it to the Limit
what does that leave us for possible
values that X can take on
yeah I can go really large it can go
infinitely large so X could be a zero it
could be one it could be two and it
could be up to Infinity
it's very unlikely to be Infinity uh but
you know is defined over all those
numbers
it's a really interesting thing we're
talking about time time is continuous
but poisson is a discrete random
variable it's talking about number of
events you can't have half an event it's
like somebody's like oh I kind of want
to write that doesn't happen you either
want the ride and you request it or you
don't
and if you define something to be a
poisson you immediately inherit this
gorgeous equation you immediately
inherit the knowledge of how you can
relate number of events with the
probability of getting those number of
events it's a magical thing
okay
there is a lot of things that fit this
narrative
this narrative is going to fit whenever
something occurs over time
and you want to know about the number of
events within a fixed time window that's
the narrative for a poisson
there are some underlying assumptions
for the poisson you know we were kind of
flipping coins at an even rate so we're
assuming that our events they're evenly
distributed over your time segment
lots of things follow this story like
um
you know number of earthquakes within
one year radioactive decay within the
next hour hits to a web server all these
things are counting number events within
a fixed period of time and you can
immediately inherit all this mathematics
you don't have to redefrive it every
time you see a story like this
the assumption is that events are
arriving at a rate where there's Lambda
events per interval of time and the
assumption that this Lambda is somehow
constant over your period is not
changing too much
how we got here is we did this crazy
thought experiment where we took our
time and split it into in the limit
infinite sub intervals
and we got the poisson
now the reader
we derived the poisson this is what a
poisson looks like this is a poisson
with rate of five so for those those
ride sharing requests we said on average
there's five requests per minute
and with just the one piece of
information all of this structure arises
you tell me there's five requests per
minute and I can tell you the
probability of getting zero requests I
can tell you probably have one request I
can tell you the probability that you'll
get 12 requests
and I just needed one piece of
information how wonderful is that there
are other things that you can do with
the poisson uh you can know the
expectation and variance which we'll
talk about in a second
um but long story short poisson you just
have a rate and it gives you a whole
probability Mass function
uh and really this is the major learning
key if somebody asks you a question if
they give you a rate so an average
number of occurrences per time interval
and they care about the probability of
number occurrences that's your narrative
that you're looking for
the one tricky thing that I'm going to
point out early is
people will give you a rate within
one-time interval and you have to make
sure that the units for that rate match
the units of your probability question
so somebody says you know there's an
average request per minute and they say
what's the probability of number
requests within one hour obviously you
have to make those two match and you
just multiply your request by minutes by
60. so from that one number how can you
know that the poisson distribution is
going to be an accurate representation
of the entire probability
this is a good question I mean as long
as something follows the Bostonian
process
then that's all all the structure just
comes because of the nature of limits in
mathematics and so so the Assumption
here is that I'm saying that requests
over my minute are just as likely to
come in in the first segment of the
minute in the last segment of the minute
that's a pretty reasonable request a
reasonable assumption
and then you have poisson and you could
observe it you know like if they look at
their logs they would see this in their
historical data it has been shown time
and time again it's such a crazy cool
thing it's so crazy cool
yeah it's saying on average there's five
requests per minute but it's certainly
saying it's possible to get two requests
it's possible to get seven requests it's
possible to get 18 requests is just very
unlikely and so you just told me the
average and I was able to expand from
that average to all the queries you
might want to know like the chance of
eight or nine or ten so the poisson very
much allows for more than five requests
per time segment
American
video
um
if it's following the assumptions I said
I will tell you exactly what the
variance will be and you will be
pleasantly surprised follow along
because this wonderful journey is not
over shall we go look into the variants
now because we've looked at this
probability Mass function we've created
here uh about the beauty that we got
just from knowing the rate and that's
not where the story ends
uh oh my gosh I did prepare to take us
down that chapter but before we go into
talking about variance can we hold that
thought and can I just do a concrete
example
okay here is my concrete example
real numbers uh this is from uh Earth
major earthquakes uh within the Western
Hemisphere
so in the Western Hemisphere there's an
average of 2.79 major earthquakes per
year
that's the only information I'm going to
give you and now I'm going to ask you a
probably question what's the probability
of three major earthquakes next year
are you allowed to give a rate that's
not a whole number absolutely your
average doesn't have to be a whole
number your query must be a whole number
because it doesn't make sense to ask
what's the chance of getting 2.7 uh
major earthquakes they're going to be a
whole number of earthquakes we have all
the information we need
it's as simple as declare X to be the
number of earthquakes next year
recognize that it's a poisson because
you're asking for a number of events
with an interval of time you have to
provide a rate when you declare a
poisson you have to give that Lambda but
we were told what it was 2.79
and when you say 2.79 poisson you
immediately inherit this graph which
says this is the chance of zero
earthquakes one earthquake two
earthquake three earthquakes of course
this graph is represented by this
beautiful equation
and you could just plug into this
beautiful equation what's the
probability that x equals three so
putting a 3 in for k
a 2.79 in for Lambda and then reducing
and you get that there's a 23 chance of
having a major earthquake next year
it's so beautiful it's natural to doubt
it
this can't be real there must be some a
huge assumption there must be something
wrong so somebody did this research
somebody wrote the the paper which is is
the sequence of earthquakes in Southern
California with aftershocks removed
poissonian
and there's two interesting things about
this paper
they come to the conclusion that it is
in fact Bostonian and it's also the
paper in the world with the shortest
abstract you guys want to see the
abstract
how bold is that they're just like yes
done screw your reviewer too anyways you
know you studied the actual distribution
they're like in fact all of these
predictions that we come from just doing
pure math play out in the real world and
that math that we just solved is in fact
the true probability of getting three
major earthquakes
oh my gosh there's so many more cool
things I have to tell you about poisson
the next cool thing I have to tell you
about poisson is
in fact
because of the nature of how we drive
poisson recall that we got the poisson
by taking the binomial and taking it
into the limit it can also do this neat
other trick which is sometimes you have
a binomial distribution problem which
has this n choose k
foreign
and that term can get so big that it can
be hard to solve a binomial probability
Mass function so a neat trick is because
the poisson is defined by taking the
binomial to a limit if your binomial
problems become so big you can sometimes
use a poisson to approximate a binomial
if the binomial looks like it's going to
the Limit you guys ready for this why
would you do this well historically
people didn't have super computers so
this was a really big deal if you could
approximate a binomial but there's two
reasons one it could save you some
compute power I'm not sure where that
motivated by Saving compute power but
the second one is I really want to build
this intuition of where the poisson
comes from and by recognizing the
poisson as a process to approximate a
binomial you'll get a deeper intuition
for what the poisson is really about
does that sound good
okay let's do it I have another question
for you
I think this is such an interesting
future that we might walk into
all the movies images emails and other
Digital Data from more than 600
smartphones could fit in this little
pink drop if we figure out how to store
data on DNA and it's looking like that's
a possibility and for lots of reasons we
might want to have data that persists
more than what we're able to do with
hard drives right now
so let's play with this interesting
scenario and let's think about the
possibility of storing data on DNA and
the interesting question for us to
consider is what's the possibility of
corruption
so let's say we put all of our
information onto DNA storage what's the
probability that like less than one
percent of it becomes corrupt
in DNA but also if you're thinking about
a real storage device you have a lot of
things that you're restoring you have a
very large string of data in this case
we're going to imagine that we're going
to put all of our information on a
string of length 10 to the power of 4.
so a pretty long string
the probability of Corruption of any one
base pair is rather small
but we would like it for very few of our
base pairs to become corrupted
now this is a binomial
if you want to talk about the number of
base pairs that get corrupted it's like
each letter in your string is a coin
flip this is the chance that it comes up
heads and we can talk about the number
of Corruptions aka the number of heads
in our 10 to the fourth coin flips
and that's fine it is a binomial the
dynomial is completely correct but now
you have to do you know in the
polynomial probability Mass function
there's this term and it's going to
involve the N choose k k might be
reasonable
but n might be 10 to the power 4 and
this could be a really really unwieldy
large number to compute
so if we can't just solve problems with
the binomial directly what could we do
Play Ultimate Frisbee go have a good day
no we can approximate we can approximate
this with a poisson
and why can we approximate this kind of
looks like our thought experiment from
the beginning of class where we took
time and we broke it into 10 000
milliseconds
those 10 000 milliseconds were n
approaching infinity and 10 to the
fourth is clearly not Infinity but
you're getting closer to Infinity so we
could set up a poisson that looks like
this binomial it's so backwards because
the video class we're like setting up a
um we're setting of the binomial to look
like a poisson and we're now we're doing
the poisson to look like a binomial but
so it goes that is just the full circle
of life
so I'm going to call these extreme nnp
and they arrive in many cases uh and you
know there's a few examples for people
who are early days of the internet were
often trying to figure out what to do
about server crashes and a lot of it had
to do with being able to think about
this probability problem
so let's revisit this problem
and let's say we couldn't solve any pmf
for that binomial so what we're going to
do is we're going to come up with an
approximating poisson this is not a
poisson process but since that n was so
close to infinity and it was a binomial
getting closer to Infinity it's going to
look like a poisson but which poisson
does it look like
we have to choose a rate
and before you know how we chose P to be
equal to Lambda over n
now we have to choose a Lambda
and if you want to choose a Lambda you
could use this same equation you can say
I want the Lambda that's equal to n
times p
if you think about it n times P should
give you your expected number of
occurrences and in this case if you
multiply those two numbers it's 0.01
now we can
we can say what's the probability of K
Corruptions for example you can put in
what's the probability of zero
Corruptions and you're like wait but
that leaves you with a zero factorial oh
my gosh you're going to be divided by
zero there's gonna be a sad time run
away
I don't know who did this is it just a
definition but there's a beautiful thing
about the world zero factorial is not
zero
it's one what a time to be alive so this
is actually a really good place to be
because this is just equal to e to the
power of negative Lambda and we just
Define Lambda to be equal to 0.01 so
this is just e to the power of zero
point negative 0.01 and saying the
chance of zero Corruptions uh is
actually 0.99
so if you had this corruption rate you
could say oh I feel rather confident
that I probably won't get a single
corruption and this could be a
reasonable way to store data
crazy thing to do
now I need to give you guys some guard
rails because with such great powerful
or wait such great power comes such
great responsibility right
you need to know when you can use this
approximation
you have to do it when
n times p is moderate so I'm going to
Define moderate to be any of the thing
that satisfies these two rules
um and it's supposed to be useful when n
goes to Infinity but you know 100 turns
out to be close enough Infinity for this
to work pretty well let me just show you
what I mean by that
here's a binomial with n is 10 and P is
0.3 that's the Red Bar
the green bar is certainly not Infinity
it's n a hundred it's 150 no
but both of these are approaching a
poisson of three because if you took
your n times P you would get a three and
look how similar that poisson is to both
of these binomials
even when n is very far from an infinity
when you get this value of n being much
larger than P you have very small P you
have kind of moderately large n the
poisson actually looks like a really
good approximation
now for these small numbers you can do
the binomial exactly but this is just to
show you that you know if your n is
probably higher than 100 and your p is a
small number certainly you're going to
get an incredible approximation with a
plus sign again what are our learning
goals here
it's a new trick it's a tool you can use
it and also it's to help reinforce this
connection between the binomial and the
poisson because that's just a beautiful
thing
okay and then we have a new major key
poisson you can use it to proximate
binomial when n is large and P is small
ah now it's time for some tender moments
with the poisson as you recall uh
moments is the really fancy term for
expectation and variance the expectation
is called the first moment and the
variances the second Central moment yes
why do we need the assumption that MP is
moderate
uh good question I think it really is
one way of expressing that you want P to
be small and N to be large and I guess
yeah if n was large so like what if n
was large and P was large I think if n
is large and P is large it actually does
lead to some weirdness where it doesn't
actually work out so um
so
oh well if Lambda is if Lambda is a
moderate number and if that if we're
defining it then you're fine so we
defined Lambda to be uh we got this P
when we were approximating the poisson
with a binomial but now we're
approximating the binomial poisson
somebody could throw a binomial at you
where the Lambda is not reasonable where
it's a very different number
okay
someone asked the wonderful question
what about variance like what if your
events have high variance like what's
going on with the variance of this
poisson and does it ever start to break
and I have such a beautiful piece of
information to share with you
recall for the binomial
we have the expectation of a binomial
and that's just n times P of so if
somebody gives you a binomial and they
say give me the expectation you just
have to multiply those two parameters
together if somebody gives you a
binomial and they ask for the variance
you multiply your two parameters
together and then you multiply it times
1 times p and then you give them back
the variance
we have to think about what expectation
and variance should be for a poisson so
let's imagine
we have our Lambda and Lambda really
comes from an N times P where n is going
to infinity and P is going to zero
are you guys ready for this is beautiful
Lambda is our one parameter and the
expectation of our random variable
you know it because it's a binomial and
the expectation of binomial is n times p
in the limit this n times p is just how
we derive Define Lambda
so in the limit the expectation is just
your rate
and you're like wait no that actually
just kind of makes sense you told me
that the average number of events per
time frame was Lambda and now you're
telling me that the average number of
events per time period is Lambda that's
actually just kind of circular like okay
okay that's just fine
but wait for this one
what's the variance of this random
variable
well here's the variance of your
binomial and of course the poisson
approximates the binomial or is the
binomial in the limit n times P that's
how we Define Lambda
and what about when p goes to zero as n
goes to Infinity what's 1 minus P that's
just one and you're like the variance is
also Lambda everything about this
poisson Lambda the expectation Lambda
the variance is Lambda and you're like
what if your number of events is a
hundred per time frame variance is a
hundred
if it's a thousand variance is a
thousand it's always given to you you
give me the rate and I can tell you the
variance in fact that variance is equal
to exactly the rate uh what a gorgeous
beautiful world we live in
so yes I have such great news for you
expectation and variance of poisson are
in fact the same and they're in fact
Lambda yes
dysfunction for like all croissants or
is this just specifically what Hassan's
being used
sorry this is this is back to the
general poisson so even if you're just
using a natural poisson these are your
expectation and variance
Wild
somebody's like I just can't believe it
this is just so mind-bending okay brings
a tear to my eye
okay this is a random aside this is a
real license plate that I saw at
Stanford uh poisson a three and I
imagine it's just somebody who like
realized that for with the rate of three
they actually had a Plus on and it
brought a tear to their eye and then
they got a vanity plate and I wish I had
that many plate but I don't that's not
important right now
okay
um now the only thing that's giving us
angst is it feels like there was a lot
of assumptions that must be made for the
poisson to occur we said like you know
as long as a process occurs with a
relatively fixed rate you'll get poisson
and I have good news
let's say you make that assumption about
that what we call the poisson process
assumption that your rate's not changing
and now the occurrence of one event is
not changing the probability of another
event occurring
even if you start to
um
uh break those assumptions the poisson
still ends up being incredibly good and
so there's this whole idea of the
poisson Paranormal and you just think of
poisson being like the most chill random
variable you're like I've got a rate and
then somebody's like well is it a
poisson process is my is your Lambda
constant over time you're like kinda and
you're like well does it fit the coin
flip metaphor where like one coin Flip's
not really changing the chance of
another one you're like kind of but you
know like maybe somebody requested and
they tell their friend and then their
friend request it because they're going
the same place and poisson's chill
they're like yeah you've kind of
violated my assumptions but you know
what I'm still gonna give you a great
probability anyways so you can still
apply a poisson approximation when uh
successes are not entirely independent
like coin flips in a binomial and um
when the there's a small variation in
the probability of success over your
time frame it's just that amazing
okay let's do a couple examples before
we jump into thinking about something
more interesting
um
like the probability of extreme weather
okay this is one for you guys to do I've
been talking a lot about poisson you
guys know it's a cool thing now but do
you have the power of the poisson
yourselves
so this is what a croissant problem
could look like see if you can figure it
I'm going to give you guys two minutes
to think about it think about it first
for a little bit but please please do
make a friend and talk to the person
next to you
okay
ah
fantastic
nothing in this problem says Plaza
explicitly but this problem screams
poisson now that we are educated people
so the reason that this screams plus saw
is a few reasons we're talking about the
number of events happening within a time
period so we're saying number of hits to
a server within one second
apply to one second absolutely you can
apply to a year it can apply to a second
apply to a minute you know you could
take a second and break into infinitely
many uh subsections just like you could
do a minute
so for this reason the poisson seems
like it'll be a great uh
great thing to use in this case the only
thing you'd need if you wanted to use a
poissons you need to know the average
number of events per time frame and
huzzah here it is in the past server
load averages two hits per second
and as we now know as soon as somebody
gives you a narrative that fits the
poisson and they give you a rate you
immediately inherit expectation and
variance and the full probability Mass
function which means you could ask
questions like what's the probability
that x equals zero
now of course the one interesting thing
here is this isn't asking the
probability that x equals zero it's
asking if it probably X is less than
five and now you think about it Chris
never told you how you can take a
poisson and answer probably like the
question like the probably the x is less
than five I only give you an equation
phrase saying the probability that X
takes on a specific value k
but
some engineering student is like oh I
know what to do we're just going to take
our good friend the for Loop in
mathematics which looks like this and
we're going to for loop from I equals
zero up until four inclusive and we're
going to add up the probability that x
equals I
so this is a very fancy way of saying
take the problem x equals zero add it to
the probably that x equals one adds to
probably x equals two three four and
then you're done
since they're all mutually exclusive
probabilities we can just add them up
you can only do addition when your
events are mutually exclusive but
assignments to a random variable are
mutually exclusive events so
my solution would look like this I
Define and declare to all who will
listen acts as a poisson and I have to
give the parameter which is two
then I say exactly this the probably the
x is less than five is the sum of all of
these probably Mass functions and then I
could just plug in this beautiful
equation we derived earlier for the
probably Mass function of a poisson if x
was not a poisson obviously I wouldn't
be able to use this probably Mass
function since it is I get all this math
for free I didn't have to derive the
probability of a binomial in the limit
and then you could just plug this into a
calculator and if you get that this
gives you a 95 problem 90 probability of
95 that you'll get less than five hits
uh within a second
okay
questions
[Music]
so one thing that's pretty important is
like
when you're choosing your values okay
and left on the third within the same
time frame right okay it happened every
two seconds and 11 differently like five
seconds it wouldn't really work so I
wanted to work that through yeah you
have to adjust though but my question is
I think we're the same time
for example so
if it was more hits every two seconds
then with the probability that X is less
than 10 would be the same well we'll
call the K is your query
so what what's your query and it has to
be an integer what was your query
oh you want to say like K is now you
were talking about you want what's four
hits within two seconds right
yeah
okay and now you have a rate that's
provided within one second I could solve
this using X or let's let's call it y
as my poisson
and now my y will be the number of
events not in one second but in two
seconds and in that case what should be
my rate for a number of events within
two seconds
to do
four yeah
uh and then you could say what's the
probability that you know
um why
equals four
and if you worked out the probably that
y equals four uh I believe it will be
equivalent to if you did the probably
that X took on the value too
no those are slightly because four hits
within two seconds it's a similar but
slightly different question than two
hits within one second yeah so there
will be slightly different numbers yeah
okay
but interesting interesting thought
experiment yeah you can do all those
things you can ask about questions
slightly outside the time frame you just
have to adjust your rate to make it work
can I just tell you some cool stuff so
at this point I want you guys to be
thinking where does this show up in my
life
because I don't run Uber pool uh like
will I actually see this I'd say poisson
is one of those things that people
should know about but don't know about
which means that there's all these math
algorithms out there waiting for
somebody just recognize that they're
poisson and I will give you two examples
once from my own life uh and ones from a
colleague's life cauliflife is certainly
more interesting than mine but my my
experience was I went to a doctor and
they're trying to measure they're trying
to track inflammation that I had over
time so I went to the doctor one day and
their accounting number of cells and
they got four
and then I they came in you know I came
in a few weeks later and they counted
number of cells and they said I have
five and they said your inflammation's
gotten worse
and immediately I was like oh because of
the same way that you can drive a
croissant over time you can do it over
space I'll have you guys do this in a
section problem I was like oh as soon as
you tell me
um that my number of inflammation cells
is four using some math I'll learn we'll
learn later in class I could infer
distribution over rates and then I can
tell I was like okay the probability
that I've gotten worse is only like 0.56
and I could know exactly that just
because of
my knowledge of poisson and of course
it's not so useful for me in that one
case but then the doctor learns you know
there was this like oh wait we've been
measuring inflammation this whole time
we didn't know that because this process
is poissonian we can tell people you
know usable probabilities addition so
anyway small thing in my life maybe the
more interesting thing in my colleague's
life is
do you guys know Google has this photo
app that lets you take photos when it's
really really dark
Has anyone used that photo app
okay you can be like basically pitch
deck pitch black you can put a sheet of
piano music you can take a photo and you
can read that piano music and I don't
know if you guys use old school digital
cameras but that absolutely wasn't
possible
and the reason that we were able to do
this very magical thing of taking photos
in incredible dark is because somebody
realized that the way that photons were
hitting camera was coming in as a
poisson process and because of that they
could take lots of photos and they could
remunerate some of the uncertainty in
the poisson and end up with really high
resolution photos and it's just like oh
yeah this incredible natural phenomena
leads to all these small magical things
in the world now none of these things
have really changed the world but it's
just gorgeous how there's these small
little ways that we can use math to do
something tiny and magical in our worlds
so anyways the poisson I think it's kind
of a cool thing
that was such a random side
okay I am going to give us our two
minute pedagogical pause before we talk
about probability for extreme weather so
take two minutes uh go the bathroom
break if you need to and we'll continue
this conversation
okay
okay and we're gonna just we're going to
get some real data we're gonna look at
some some real stuff here
um I I've downloaded a whole bunch of
hurricane data and we're going to think
about probability of extreme weather
um but before we do that any questions
this is our chance to have a nice little
conversation about our good friend
poisson
hopefully during that that two minute
break you had a moment to crystallize
what we've done like that derivation we
did at the beginning is kind of a big
deal because I want you to know that
Narrative of where the poisson comes
from so like just knowing that beautiful
derivation is a cool thing then knowing
a poisson being able to recognize it and
use it that's also a cool thing and then
we have these two nicest sides one was
the expectation the variance of poisson
and then we also talked about the
poisson approximating a binomial so
those two nicest sides and then of
course the most important thing is that
you just get some practice with
poissons
and that's what we're going to do next
so
the US has been paying attention to
hurricanes for a long time and they've
been recording it since 1851 and this is
a histogram that I made and I just made
it off the public data that the US
Reports on hurricanes within the
Atlantic so every year here is just a
histogram saying that like in this year
this is the number of hurricanes and and
if you look at it over time you kind of
get this feeling that there's more
hurricanes now than there used to be
and I was just wondering can we just
dive into that and see if we can tell
that story a little bit more formally
than just like hey check out my cool
graph it goes that way
so what I'd like to do is let's actually
go to the code and let's use our
computer science skills uh and our
understanding of poisson now to to try
and understand this
so here's the data that I've got for us
it's the heard that data that's what
they call this database of hurricanes
and every single row here is a hurricane
it tells you things like where the
hurricane was uh if it had a name and it
also tells you like the strength of the
hurricane so a lot of information and
importantly it also has when the
hurricane took place
so I have some code for us to use the
first thing I had to do is
we're talking about number of hurricanes
within one year that seems to be the
random variable that I'm curious about
I have every reason to believe it's
poissonian you know well actually the
assumption that the number of hurricanes
is consistent throughout your time
period is violated but it you know how
we talked about how the poisson still
works when you violate the assumptions
mildly it turns out hurricanes still
look very very poissonian even though
they're a bit seasonal
so even though hurricanes are seasonal
if you think about number of hurricanes
within a year that distribution
historically looks very poissonian so I
believe it's quasanian I have data
and I just need to extract a single
number from that data what I need from
the data is I need to know
the rate
I need to know the average number of
hurricanes in one year and once I know
that rate that's all I need to
understand the full distribution for
probabilities within a time frame which
means that this code is actually pretty
straightforward
um
so my code is going to load all the data
and then basically I'm going to Loop
over every year I'm going to sum up how
many hurricanes took place in my range
of years and then my rate is very simply
wait for it number of hurricanes I
counted divided by the number of years
in my range and that's the only piece of
information I needed as soon as I have
this rate I can declare I think I have a
poisson and I'm going to say here's my
years here's my rate I'm going to say
X's number of hurricanes a year I'm
going to declare it to be a poisson with
this particular rate
and then what I have here is I'm going
to just really quickly show you how you
can use a poisson in Python
the stats package has a poisson and that
poisson module has a probably Mass
function so you can say I have a poisson
with this rate
call it X and then you can say x dot pmf
and you can put in zero and it'll give
you a probability that this poisson
takes on the value of zero you have pmf1
you get the probability that it takes on
One in fact to kind of illuminate this
I'm going to loop from 0 to 40. I'm
going to say what's the probability of X
is zero what's the problem that X is one
should we take a look
this isn't exactly solving uh my problem
but it's just exploring
this data
um
python explore hurricanes
okay
so I'm looking at hurricanes I looked in
115 years in fact I was looking at the
years 1851 to 1966.
that's 115 years over those 115 years we
saw 975 hurricanes that leaves a rate of
8.5 hurricanes and as soon as I see this
because I think the process seems plus
onion I'm going to say the number of
hurricanes in a year that random
variable is going to be a poisson with
Lambda equal to the rate I calculated
as soon as you do this you inherit the
probability Mass function this is just
one way of expressing it I'm going to
say
this is zero hurricanes and this is the
chance to gain zero hurricanes here's
one hurricane chance getting one
hurricane two hurricanes chance of
getting two hurricanes based on this
rate I got from historical data
okay which means I can start to answer
questions
but
the first thing maybe we should look
into before we get into a more
philosophical questions is was poisson a
good approximation
so
I looked at my historical data I pulled
out Lambda of 8.5 that Lambda of 8.5
gives me this blue distribution for the
probability of zero one two three so on
hurricanes per year
let's just compare that to the histogram
of hurricanes per year how many times
did we see 10 hurricanes well that's the
Orange Line how many times we see 20
hurricanes because there's only 115
samples you wouldn't expect this to be a
perfect match but that's a pretty good
match that's what it looks like when
natural phenomena follows a poisson like
you could have predicted that shape
pretty well just by knowing the average
even though hurricanes mildly violate
the Assumption of the poisson it's close
enough that we really get a good Insight
from a single number
but that's not really my question my
question wasn't uh
what's the the distribution of
hurricanes I want to know is the
distribution changing
so what I did is we calculated this rate
up to 1966.
now let's take this poisson and see how
well does it predict the number of
hurricanes in a year after 1966.
so
I looked at that data and I noticed that
there is a couple years
when you start to see more than 15
hurricanes in a year and the poisson
says that's pretty unlikely
I want to show what it could look like
to make an argument that like oh it
looks like the distribution has changed
or what we would call shifted what's the
probability of having a year with 15
hurricanes
so
if there's a year with 15 hurricanes I'm
going to say that's pretty improbable
based on this plus song but can I
quantify that
if x is the number of hurricanes a year
and X is a poisson 8.5 what's the
probability of getting more than 15
hurricanes and let's do this in the code
I want to use
this code and figure out what's the
probability of more than 15 or is it
yeah more than 15 hurricanes
oh this says more than 15 hurricanes
so I have X
it's a poisson
I can ask it's probability Mass function
that's the API you have access to can we
use our code to calculate exactly the
probability of getting 15 or more
hurricanes in a year
now what we really should do is we
should sum over all those values that
satisfy greater than 15.
so here's what I'm planning to do I'm
going to write a for Loop
and that for Loop is going to run from I
equals 16 because we're not including a
0 up to 15 up to Infinity
I'm going to add the probability that x
equals I why is this a bad idea
well
it is correct this technically is the
probability of getting 16 or more
hurricanes it's probably getting 16
hurricanes plus probably getting 17 plus
the probability of getting 18. it's
correct
but why is this not going to be a fun
thing to code up
let's just try we'll do like four uh in
range uh 16 to is it like math.infinity
yeah my computer's gonna get tired uh-oh
wait do we not have the ability to ask
the question what's the probability that
um X is greater than 15.
ah somebody knows
yes you can take the complement of from
the spirit of 15.
probably X is less than 15 is 1 minus
the probability sorry that's greater
than 15 is one minus probably the x is
less than or equal to 15.
uh
and that is much easier to calculate
probably that X is less than or equal to
15 just means I have to loop from 0 up
to
16 which is
man range is such a funny thing in
Python
okay so here I get I but I don't want I
I want the probability that x equals I
in math we call that the probability
Mass function and in Python if I want to
look at the probably math function of I
for this poisson random variable X I
just do x dot pmf
I'm going to do probability
starting at zero
I'm simply going to add up each of these
probably Mass functions you know I'm
going to be doing the sum from 1 to 15.
now I'm not supposed to report that
number I'm supposed to report 1 minus
that probability
so I'm going to calculate this is the
probability of 0 to 15 hurricanes and I
want 1 minus that probably that's
probably more than 15. so let's run this
it says the chance of getting
more than 15 hurricanes is about 1.3
percent
okay
so if I go back here I'm like
well they're these two years with more
than
15 hurricanes maybe that's believable it
seems unlikely but within the realm of
possibility
what looks less like it's in the realm
of possibilities since 1966 there have
been two years with more than 30
hurricanes
and can we calculate the probably of
more than 30 hurricanes absolutely we
just do the exact same thing it's just
now instead of looping from 0 to 15
we're going to Loop to 30.
and the probability of having a year
with more than 30 hurricanes assuming
the distribution that we modeled going
up to 1966
is 1 minus 0.99999999999 and then a
bunch of nines and then seven
it's incredibly unlikely the number of
hurricanes that we've seen and in fact
um
if I plot the data after 1966
it no longer looks like it's coming from
this poisson in fact it looks like it's
coming from a poisson but a different
looking poisson a poisson with a much
higher rate
and so this is a pretty good argument
that the rate of recorded hurricanes up
till 1966 looks very different from the
rate of recorded hurricanes afterwards
now
there's a lot of stories that we're
talking about certainly one of the first
things that should come to mind is this
incredible change that has happened to
our Earth there is a lot more CO2 in the
world that means that there's a lot more
heat in the atmosphere which means a lot
more energy for Hurricane so certainly
this is a hypothesis for why we think
there could be a distribution shift
it turns out this has led to more
extreme hurricanes but it turns out this
is not the exact answer for why there is
such a big distributionship in number of
hurricanes so more energy in the
atmosphere means that when we have
hurricanes they tend to be bigger but it
doesn't necessarily mean more uh
hurricanes so I want to have another
hypothesis
which you guys want to know
okay
here's what happened in 1966 they
started using
um they started using satellites to
track hurricanes and so before 1966 you
would only catch a hurricane if somebody
reported the hurricane and after 1966 we
would catch any hurricane that ever
existed so was there distribution ship
in recorded hurricanes absolutely
because we got a lot better at recording
hurricanes so it looked like there's
many more hurricanes per year so there's
more extreme hurricanes because of
climate change but that distribution
shift turns out it came from satellites
anyways there you go
um here I put all the python things you
might want to know they're in the slides
come back next time and we're going to
continue this wonderful story thank you
guys so much have a wonderful rest every
week come back on Friday and we will
learn more cool things okay have a good
one